foreign
[Music]
I almost can't believe we're finally
here
I've reviewed so many products over my
Lifetime on YouTube that's almost
ridiculous and the question always comes
up in the background well Marquez when
are you gonna make design your own
product right so two years of materials
work and design work and basically a
lifetime of inspiration later
I'm actually holding the thing this is
the first one it's called m251 why is it
called 251 you might be asking good
question I'm glad you asked so this is
still a collaboration after all I could
have all the ideas for shoe stuff in the
world but I still need someone to build
the shoe so Adams is the company that's
come through for me on this one they've
had their model triple o and then model
001 they've inhaled some of the most
comfortable shoes of all time and I
agree but this would be something
completely new for both of us the length
of my first ever YouTube video on Tech
yeah that one was two minutes and 51
seconds long
a new beginning
and that's also sort of a new beginning
[Music]
now if you know me you already knew I
like shoes but I'm not suddenly a shoe
designer out of nowhere so the idea was
that I would take all sorts of bits and
pieces from different shoes that I like
shoes that I've worn shoes that I've
seen and try to combine as many of that
in one place as I possibly can so the
lightweightness of nmds uh the
silhouette of Jordan Ones things like
the the soul and the elastic laces of
Adam's shoes and the little bits and
details and Tiny things from Blazers and
off-white collabs and so we went through
a lot of prototypes and a lot of things
like that to sort of accomplish that put
them all in one place so the process was
really fun actually and we went through
as many combinations as possible and
went through a ton of different ideas
and Designs we're trying to figure out
what was possible and what wasn't in a
shoe we have a lot of older prototypes
that we didn't go with that had things
like fitment issues and support issues
and material issues and we went through
and basically Adams could tell me like
this will be possible versus this won't
be possible this will be more expensive
versus this won't be more expensive and
so all the different parts of the shoe
had to come together from our
combination of expertise and my taste it
was one of the most fun processes I've
ever gone through and then the other
part of that was I literally got to wear
them around and start testing them so
once we got working prototypes like this
one I wore for weeks literally started
showing up in videos by accident just
because I was just daily driving these
things every day testing my own creation
so we went through dozens of samples
over two plus years I mean this is a
long process where like we have an idea
for a YouTube video and we can make that
in a couple of days this is something
that's been in our heads and in the
background for a long time but we
finally have come to a final version and
I really really like it and I'm now
excited to like get you guys to actually
wear it and try it yourselves so now I
can review my own product actually I'm
really excited for other shoe reviewers
to be able to do that but what I can do
is tell you all about it so the
silhouette is pretty simple right it's
not fully high top but obviously not a
low top either it's a really comfortable
daily mid and this upper is a combo of
synthetic leather and then we actually
have a recycled mesh fabric that's a
nice balance between breathable and
supportive and I took a lot of samples
to get that right and if you're curious
development wise this Soul was actually
the hardest part so I'm on my feet all
day my job as a video producer in this
studio does involve a lot of walking
it's a lot of moving around and
crouching and kneeling and all kinds of
stuff like that so Comfort is a high
priority so this outsole has to be
supportive enough to actually function
and hold up the shoe so it doesn't
collapse but also still be soft enough
through the midsole that's really
comfortable and this bottom sole is
proprietary it's all very I don't know
camp together super nicely we also did
something a little bit interesting just
if you see the the shape along the side
so this is a little bit structural it's
a little Heel To Toe drop so if you're
used to wearing shoes that are a lot
flatter like Jays or Converses you will
notice and feel a bit of a difference
with this shape and it's really good
there's a copper lining in here that's
naturally antimicrobial which does help
prevent odors which is awesome my
signature and size stamp is on the
tongue we've got this loop on the back
too which is actually functional and
that's where we put the atoms logo which
is the top one here and the MKBHD
parallelogram in the same style and of
course the elastic laces underrated a
lot of people don't know about these but
you can sort of just treat them like
normal laces maybe tie them a little
looser or tighter and then they Flex a
little bit to support your foot as
you're moving around
there's little details like the New York
City Tag the 251 is stitched even um
taking it apart even the soul is a
custom designed and it kind of Cups your
foot a little bit and is soft as well
all this stuff is awesome I really
couldn't be happier with how these
turned out now if you get these you have
to promise me one thing
wear your kicks I I am such like there's
this whole culture of like you get shoes
and then you have to like baby them and
take really good care of them for proper
resale value no no you gotta actually
daily these and like wear them out and
put them to work I still get I still get
roasted on Instagram for like crouching
down in a picture and then the toe boxes
crease and then all the comments are
like what are you doing you're ruining
your shoes no wear your kicks crease
your kicks wear them in all four seasons
I'm gonna be dailying these things we
put a lot of work into the engineering
of them to be able to do that so winter
spring summer fall snow mud uh you'll be
able to see mine on social media getting
dirty as I wear them a ton we love that
so I'm gonna make sure these are
available as worldwide as we possibly
can and maybe you'll even see me pop up
in a retail shop once in a while to help
just get the word out about them and I
hope if you get them that you wear them
too so this 251 is an exciting New
Beginning
also I've been waiting a long time to do
this
[Music]